on this fateful day in Massachusetts a
new era of Patriots football begins the
Jimmy Garoppolo here coach Bill
Belichick leads his Patriots onto the
field against a familiar foe the
Pittsburgh Steelers led by coach Mike
Tomlin and big Ben Roethlisberger young
Jimmy struggled early on and in trouble
getting a handle on the football and
overthrowing his receivers on the other
side of the football it was business as
usual for Big Ben
he toss Patriots defenders aside running
and throwing the Steelers to a
two-touchdown lead at halftime Jimmy has
offered some advice from a pair of
familiar faces quarterback Tom Brady and
his wife Gisele gimme gimme
come over here Gisele Tom are you guys
doing here we want to help here
tres played football no way or get in
trouble who Freddy's up here no way
hugs are for girls everybody knows that
this game a little grub jimmy critics
when i play the game because i'd love it
Tom not just to hold a stupid trophy and
marry a super Jimmy entered the second
half motivated by his love of football
he played like it from Kowski carried
Steelers into the endzone and brought
the Patriots to it then forward then the
Steelers offense stalled again you can
Garoppolo one more chance to win the
game with 10 seconds remaining it seemed
like Garoppolo would win the game for
the Pats until Mike Tomlin stepped into
the situation the 15 the 10 the five
toddler Mike Tomlin prep City Garoppolo
he doesn't get in the Steelers win the
Steelers head coach stripped the young
quarterback just before the end zone and
as time expired a tough loss for the
young quarterback leaving Garoppolo
feeling deflated his dreams crushed